[Musique]
des milliers de tonnes de rails
s'entassent en périphérie de caen pechea
l'ouest de la péninsule du yucatan les
rails viennent de chine d'autre du japon
s'accumulent de l'autre côté vers cancun
un peu plus loin des traverses en béton
devant la vieille garde comme pitch est
désaffecté depuis la fin des années 90
elle sert de bureau aux ingénieurs du
travail à un rail et traverseront
bientôt poser sur ce terreau plat
fraîchement bâti sur le tracé même de
l'ancien chemin de fer abandonnés dont
on voit encore les rails au croisement
là où un jour il y aura un pont sous
lequel passera le train maya à 160
kilomètres/heure
pour l'instant ce début
d'infrastructures c'est presque tout ce
qu'on peut voir car le reste en est
encore au stade de la vision du rêve ce
rêve c'est celui du président mexicain
andres manuel lopez obrador qui a juré
de laisser en héritage un nouvel
aéroport une raffinerie de pétrole et le
train maya
[Musique]
historique à une grande oeuvre
transcendantale historique parce qu'elle
va intégrer à la république toute la
région maya du sud et style pharaonique
c'est le terme qui revient le plus
souvent pour souligner l'ampleur du
projet
gigantesque milles 550 km de voies
ferrées tout autour de la péninsule du
yucatan dans cinq états premier objectif
évident le tourisme à la fois les plages
les sites archéologiques mais aussi le
transport de marchandises et de
passagers en dehors des zones
touristiques car la vision du président
mexicain qui est originaire de l'état
sudiste de tabasco est d'abord sociale
justice sociale pour le sud est du
mexique abandonné depuis longtemps alors
qu'il procure une richesse incalculable
en pétrole tourisme archéologie nature
et biodiversité
il doit générer le bien-être des
communes ôtez en les connectant
le constructeur des 42 premiers trains
été choisi il se trouve au mexique celle
usines de bombardier dans l'état
d'hidalgo aujourd'hui propriété d'alstom
d'être à hybride diesel électrique dont
plusieurs seront des restaurants ou de
longues distances avec couchettes la vie
des habitants de ces communautés mayas
un métis et un général positif
oui c'est bien c'est un plus du
transport sécuritaire c'est génial
beaucoup de gens vont venir et par
mercator l'avis des observateurs
attentifs est plus mitigé
c'est l'intention cette ligue tout le
monde maya grâce à cette étrange
savez que c'est déjà fait nous avons
deux autoroutes qui ne sont pas les
meilleurs du monde mais ils sont très
décembre que poutou lycée où nous
utilisons maintenant pour faire tout la
visite du monde maya pour ça c'est pas
si j'ai à dire c'est non mais c'est vrai
qu'à ce pillage
faire plus fans
pour limiter au maximum les
expropriations coûteuse en argent mais
surtout en tant les gars seront pour la
plupart hors des villes parfois des
dizaines de kilomètres
le travail est un bon projet de
développement si on respecte certaines
données ainsi le corridor de cancun à
tulum pourrait être un succès mais pour
le reste ça va donner du travail mais
après c'est un grain
privé 81
et jacques et un seul trajet qui peut
être rentable fait cancun tout le monde
en rêve en dehors de ça
blanc 240 km dont la plupart des voies
surélevées en viaduc devait être bâtie
par les militaires
mais ces forages pour préparer le
terrain ont trouvé trop de cavernes pour
risquer d'y planter des piliers le train
passera donc à ras du sol sur le tracé
de la ligne électrique à haute tension
loin de la zone hôtelière dont les
propriétaires étaient déjà opposés au
tracé initial
difficile de les voir ces travaux mais
en décembre moins de 400 kilomètres de
terre-pleins était couché il leur reste
à faire plus de 1000
aucune des vingt-et-une station dont le
design est particulièrement attirant n'a
été commencé et on ne sait même pas où
plusieurs d'entre elles seront
construites faune à tour reconnaît un
retard dû à la bureaucratie mais reste
ferme sur la date de l'inauguration
non si
on travaillera jour et nuit dit elle
jusqu'à la fin un pari impossible un
président dont le mandat se termine
précisément décembre 2023 et qui a fait
de l'accélération des travaux une
question de sécurité nationale avec des
coûts qui sont déjà passés de 8 à 12
milliards de dollars canadiens